[Music]
thank you
within the third and fourth parts of
Ursula Kayla Green's story dragonfly
these parts being called asper and erian
after two of the characters one of them
in absolutely Central character Aryan
and the other somebody who's going to
become quite important not just in this
story but in the sixth book of Earthsea
as well the one that's going to follow
this very quickly what we're going to
see depicted is a set of crises that are
affecting roke and indeed Earthsea in
general and it's precipitated and I
choose that word deliberately with an
analogy to chemistry where you add a
certain compound to some other compound
and then things precipitate out you
couldn't see them originally in the
solution and now because of something
being added something being done
everything is going to change but the
the solution was pregnant with that
change you might say it's all
precipitated by the door keeper letting
erian in and this goes back to her and
Ivory's plan about getting her into
Rogue she's not trying to hurt anybody
Ivory wants to screw things up and show
up the masters of Rogue so she gets to
the door the gate
and she knocks and a middle-aged man
stands there and says what can I do for
you and she says you can let me into the
great house sir he says do you know the
way in well this is the way in sir do
you know whose name you must tell me
before I let you in my own sir it is
irian is it he said that gave her pause
she stood silent and we're going to come
back to that topic in a bit so he says
it is your name but maybe not all your
name I think you have another I don't
know it sir after a long time she said
maybe I can learn it here sir and so he
says come in daughter he's not fooled At
All by her disguise he deliberately
brings her in knowing that this is
breaking one of the rules one of the
laws one of the traditions of rogue
her spell of semblance dropped away like
a cobweb she was and looked herself and
he's going to bring her in and says you
know would you wait here just a little
bit erian and uh then the master changer
of Rogue comes in and he introduces the
two of them and we have a description
here the changer stared openly at her he
was not as tall as she was he stared at
the door keeper and then at her again
forgive me for talking about you before
your face young woman but I must master
door keeper you know I'd never question
your judgment but the rule is clear I
have to ask you what moved you to break
it and let her come in and the
doorkeeper said
she asked me to so something is
happening here something is opening up a
world that has been closed in upon
itself and uh
uh the door keeper says when did a woman
last asked to enter the school they know
the rule doesn't allow them so we've had
this thing and we know from the previous
stories that this was not always the
case at Roe because a matter of fact
Rogue was founded originally by by women
all right and then eventually taken over
by men and what we see here is this
present crisis of a woman being admitted
to the Great Hall
through the door as a student
so they talk a little bit I about Ivory
and there's like some talk about well
maybe there was some point to him coming
in right and then there's a discussion
that's going to take place
um
the changer says my friend what is it
you think to do to learn what is she
that you ask this for her bringing her
into the council room
who we are said the doorkeeper that we
who are we so the door keeper that we
refuse her without knowing what she is
and then the next response is a woman so
the master Summoner the master Summoner
is the person who would be Arc Mage
taking ged's place
and you know controlling all of Rogue
putting it back onto a proper footing as
we're going to see him talk about and
what we see in this discussion between
the different members the different
masters of the Council of Rogue is that
irian has four people more or less
supporting her one is pretty quiet The
herbal who she takes for being a
groundskeeper at first but we have the
door keeper who has definitely committed
himself we have the Namer and the
patterner both of whom are cards and
both of whom are going to speak up on
her behalf and then all the rest are
going to be against this so
the doorkeeper says come irian and meet
the masters of roke he introduces her
earring of way my lords they were silent
he motioned her to come further into the
room the master changer you have met
right and then we have the door keeper
uh you know
speaking actually the master Summoner
speaking after the doorkeeper was done a
woman the doorkeeper nodded once mild as
ever this is what you brought the nine
together for this and no more my door
keeper says this and no more now here's
where we get through the other major
crisis this ongoing crisis that isn't
completely resolved and we'll see get
resolved in the final book of Earth see
what's going on dragons have been seen
flying above the inmo sea Rogue has no
archmage and the Island's no true Crown
King there is real work to do the
Summoner said and his voice 2 was like
Stone Cold and heavy when will we do it
so he's he's in Us in effect saying
listen this thing about this woman
coming in here this is a bad problem but
you know we've got a much bigger set of
problems that we need to resolve
and these turn out to be interconnected
right
so
the next person says did you bring this
woman into the house as a student master
door keeper if I did it would be up to
you all to approve or disapprove and
they go on and you know there's there's
a lot of considerations coming up it's
not our judgment that prevails but the
rule of Rogue which we are sworn to
follow is said by one I doubt the
doorkeeper would defy it lightly says uh
the the white-haired big man raw boned
and cragged face unlike the others he
looked at her as he spoke I am current
karamuk as the master Namer here I make
free with names and they they go on and
there's more discussion finally the
Summoner says
if you have some interest in this woman
doorkeeper it should be pursued outside
these walls outside the door you vowed
to keep
she has no place here nor ever will she
can only bring confusion dissension and
further weakness Among Us I will speak
no longer and say nothing else in her
presence and then this is where the
patterner speaks silence is not enough
my Lord and they go they go on a bit
more right
finally
we the one with a deep The Voice like a
deep tone Bell looked at her and said as
I see it the man who brought you here
meant to do harm but you do not
yet being here irian you do
your us and your self-harm everything
not in its own place does harm a note
sung however well sung wrecks the tune
it isn't part of women teach women
witches learn their craft from other
witches and from Sorcerers not from
Wizards what we teach here is in a
language not for women's tongues the
Young Heart Rebels against such laws
calling them unjust arbitrary but they
are true laws founded not on what we
want but on what is the just and the
unjust the foolish and the wise all must
obey them or waste life and come to
grief and so there's all of this stuff
going on all of this debating that's
happening much of which is happening
sort of as they position themselves in
relation to each other and what is going
to come out of this is the patterner on
the door keeper will in fact take irian
out medra's gate
and the patterner will take her to the
imminent growth the imminent Grove for
anybody who hasn't already you know read
the earlier Earthsea things is as old as
old can be it is a magical place indeed
you might say that magic not only
develops within it but flows from it
and it's much larger on the inside than
it appears from the outside and that is
where the patterner lives so the
patterner takes her to the Grove and she
lives with him there he brings her food
and
um
he doesn't do teaching in the Grove the
trees do right and there's this
beautiful line here once in the Grove
she erian had no thought of earning or
deserving or either even of learning to
be there was enough was all
so there's a kind of contentment it kind
of rest available in the Grove when she
asked him if students came there from
the great house he said sometimes
another time he said my words are
nothing hear the leaves that was all he
said that could be called teaching and
so there's a lot of discussion of what
goes on in the Grove one of the things
that's going to be particularly
important though is the patterner is
going to tell her the story
of thorian and the crisis that they are
in so this is after talking a little bit
about the cargs so he says you know or I
must speak of harm you know what dragon
brought back our Lord sparrowhawk with
the young king from the shores of death
and the dragon carried sparrowhawk away
to his home for his power was gone and
he was not a mage so presently the
masters of Rogue met to choose a new arc
Mage here in the Grove as always but not
as always
before the dragon came the Summoner had
returned from Death where he can go
where his art can take him he had seen
our Lord and the young king there in the
country across the wall of stones he
said they will not come back he said
Lord sparrowhawk had told him to come
back to us to life to bear that word so
he grieved for our Lord but then the
Dragon collessing came bearing him
living
the Summoner was among us when we stood
on Rogue Nolan saw the ark Mage kneel to
King Lebanon then as the dragon bore our
friend away the Summoner fell down he
lay as if dead cold is heart not beating
yet he breathed The herbal used all his
art but could not Rouse him he is dead
he said the breath will not leave him
but he is dead
so they set the young king in the
summoner's place to choose a new Warden
of rogue
and the changer spoke against it at
first and then agreed to it
when that happened they couldn't arrive
at a decision
we said this and said that but no name
was spoken and then he in effect
prophesied words came to me what my
people call the other breath I said
hamagondan and kuram karamokuk said told
them this in heartache a woman on gaunt
and so they had to try to figure out
what that was the king left soon after
and the master wind key went with him
before the King was to be crowned they
went to gaunt and sold our Lord
sparrowhawk but they didn't see him only
my country woman tenor of the ring she
said she was not the woman they saw it
so Lebanon judged it a prophecy yet to
be fulfilled and in hovnor he set his
crown on his own head
The herbal and I too judge the Summoner
dead we thought the breath he breathed
was left from some spell of his though
it seemed terrible to breathe a very a
breathing body yet he was cold and his
blood did not run and no soul was in him
that was more terrible so we made ready
to bury him and then as we lay beside
his grave his eyes opened he moved and
spoke he said I have summoned myself
again into life to do what must be done
so the Summoner is alive and yet dead
and feels himself to have an important
Mission now the summoner's art is one of
the deepest of majory taught on roke and
he was great friends with the archmage
himself so the Summoner has you could
say a lot of juice right he's got a lot
of legitimacy
but he's also got something
fundamentally wrong and we see him
spying in effect in perhaps a lecherous
way on
Aryan
she we've got this this uh interesting
description you know
she sat a while by the thrill burn this
this stream she was troubled by what he
told her and her thoughts and feelings
in the Grove troubled that any thought
or feeling could have troubled her here
and she goes to the the stream uh she
slipped off her sandals put her feet in
the water she slid out of her clothes
and slipped naked into the water feeling
the push and stir of the current all
along her body all trouble and
restlessness washed away from her in the
running of the water and she floated in
the Delight of the caress of the stream
gazing up at the soft white fire of the
Stars
a chill ran through the water ran cold
Gathering herself together her limbs
still soft and loose she looked up and
saw on the bank above her the black
figure of a man get away she shouted get
away you traitor you fall lateral cut
the liver out of you
she left back down the bank found her
clothes and pulled them on still
swearing aloud you coward wizard you
traitorous son of a [ __ ]
and then the patterner says you're in he
was here she cried that fall heart that
thorian I was bathing in the Stream and
he stood there watching me ascending
only a seaming of him it could not hurt
you irian ascending with eyes a seeming
with seeing may he be she stopped at a
loss suddenly for the word she felt sick
she shuddered and swallowed the cold
spittle that weld in her mouth so this
is a sort of you know there's there's a
transgression Happening Here uh the on
the part of the uh Summoner thorian
she also talks with ASR who is going to
reveal this name to her
the patterner came forward and took her
hands in his his hands were warm and she
felt so mortally cold she came up close
against him for the warmth of his body
and she says
tell me your name not your true name
only a name I can call you when I think
of you he said style he stood silent for
a minute and then said in karago at when
I was a barbarian I was osvar and
heartache that's a banner of war and so
he's given her something that she can
call him by and I should point out too
he falls in love with her
um
not at this point but it's it's clear
that that's happening especially in the
later works
now everything comes to a crisis a point
of you know tilting within this big
crisis both of her being there and of
all these other background issues that
are going on and we have a confrontation
that is going to happen particularly in
the fourth part of it but before this
what happens is the um
the patterner is going to bring the
other people
there to to you know talk about things
and we we have some other things
interestingly revealed here right so the
um
the the uh healer the The herbal says
thorian has been much with the other
Masters and what the young men secret
meetings inner circles rumors Whispers
the younger students are frightened and
several have asked me or the doorkeeper
if they may go leave Rogue and we'd let
them go but there's no ship in Port and
none has come into thrill Bay since the
one that brought you lady and sailed
next day for a watt Hort the Win key
keeps the Rogue wind against all if the
king himself should come he could not
land on Rogue
and then he says thorian says Lebanon is
not truly King since no archmage crowned
him
and the herbal goes on The Ring Of Peace
is healed the prophecy is fulfilled the
son of Moret is crowned and yet we have
no peace where have we gone wrong
why can we not find the balance
so the Namer says well what does thorian
intend to bring Lebanon here so the
herbal the young men talk of the true
Crown a second coronation by the
archmage thorian right and so all of
this is you know leading to a problem
and they're talking about this issue of
the balance or the equilibrium
so there's different approaches to this
right there's there's several different
things going on there's a reference to
the wall that separates off the Dead
from the living and the patterner says
that wall is not as old as the trees
that we live in here right the trees are
more closely connected to the
equilibrium but the uh the Namer says
you're right herbal we're out of balance
when and where did we begin to go too
far what have we forgotten turned our
back on overlooked
so
the patterner says when the balance is
wrong holding still is not good it must
get more wrong until and what's until
what he doesn't know and the neighbor
says what's more wrong than to summon
themselves back from death
The herbal says thorian was the best of
us a Braveheart a noble mind sparrowhawk
loved him so did we all
the Namer says conscience caught him
conscience told him he alone could set
things right to do it he denied his
death so he denies life
and who will stand against him said the
pattern I can hide only in my woods and
I and my tower said the name or a new
herbal and door keeper are in the Trap
the great house the walls we built to
keep all evil out or in as the case may
be
we are for against him so the patterner
they are five against us said the herbal
has it come to to this the neighbor said
that we stand on the edge of the forests
that [ __ ] planted and talk of how to
destroy one another and then the
patterner where he could have said oh
you're right we need to like come back
from the brink
he tilts it a little bit further forward
he says yes
what goes too long on Change destroys
itself the forest is forever because it
dies and dies and so lives I will not
let this dead hand touch me or touch the
king who brought us hope a promise was
made through me I spoke at a woman on
gaunt I will not see that word forgotten
right and so there's this interesting
discussion what does the pattern the
balance the equilibrium actually require
and we get two different confrontations
first the Win key shows up and the Win
key is going to come there with some
young men and tell them listen
I will allow this woman to leave
he comes into the Grove
and the wind key says we have to settle
this matter that divides us the woman
with you defies the rule of Rogue she
must leave the boat is waiting at the
dock to take her and the wind I can tell
you will stand fair for way
I have no doubt of that my lord said
osvar the patterner but I doubt she will
go
my Lord patterner this is the wind key
again will you defile our rule in our
community that has been won so long
upholding order against the forces of
Ruin will it be you of all men who break
the pattern and azra says it is not
glass to break it is breath it is fire
the wind key says Lord thorian has
returned from Death to save us all he
will be archmage under his rule roak
will be as it was the king will receive
the true Crown from his hand and Rule
with his guidance as Morad ruled no
witches will defile sacred ground no
dragons will threaten the inmo sea there
will be order safety and peace
and so there's you know he and the
students with him say let us have the
witch
she's got to go
order will be maintained order will be
restored thorian the Summoner will be
part of that and we will be following
him
now
those who are resisting the four are the
four Mages the door keeper the name or
the pattern or the herbal and irian
herself they don't know what they have
to offer instead of this old order but
they know that the old order is not
going to be
sufficient here so the wind key goes
away and then they come again but now
with the Summoner men were coming
through the gardens and up the path from
the great house the five Mages many
students leading them was thori in the
Summoner tall and his great cloak
carrying his tall staff of bone white
wood about which a faint gleam of wear
light hovered
and then here's what he says Eerie in a
way that there may be peace and Order
and for the sake of the balance of
things I bid you now to leave this
island we cannot give you what you ask
and for that we ask your forgiveness but
if you seek to stay here you forfeit
forgiveness and must learn what follows
on transgression and she tells him
come up the hill
and this is where we get to the final
confrontation and the Revelation and
realization of what year Yin is and has
been all this time and we find the
Summoner
as powerful as he is as amazing the feat
of coming back from death
is not able to withstand her
and the evil that without him realizing
it or those who followed him has been
brought in is in effect going to be
scourged from Rogue and does this
completely resolve the crises well yes
and no erian is not actually going to
stay at Rogue so the issue of can women
be there
not such an issue after that and the
other things that are going on dragons
Crossing into human territory uh the
fact that they don't have an arc Mage to
rule over things the question of the
legitimacy of King Lebanon none of these
are completely resolved but they're now
moving towards some resolutions of the
crises that we're going to see not in
this story but in the final book of the
earth sea Saga